election day in Alabama voters have
three more hours to choose between
Republican Roy Moore or Democrat Doug
Jones polls closed at 7:00 p.m. local
time 8:00 p.m. Eastern it's a race the
nation has been closely following after
the Washington Post broke a story last
month alleging more engaged in sexual
misconduct with minors decades ago can
mark pull off a victory tonight he was
down ten points according to our most
recent Fox poll we have two election
experts with us at the table tonight
Bret Baier and martha maccallum are
hosting special coverage tonight on the
Fox News Channel welcome to you both
thanks for having it here we go again
saying to Bret earlier it feels like
2016 never really ended no it never did
we've been covering the 2016 election
for you know going on three years now
yeah yeah this is gonna be fascinating
it's all gonna come down to turnout who
comes out who doesn't and I think we're
gonna get a sense of things six early
seven we'll have our own exit polls this
year voter analysis now very exciting
right fancy name yes they have a new
method what is it it's a mix of calls
and internet and I think it's gonna be
very interesting referendum tonight on
the whole issue of sexual harassment
which has obviously become so front and
center so will these voters say that
this is something that is so serious and
so egregious what Roy Moore was accused
of and he says he didn't do that it
causes them to vote against him and I
think there's gonna be a lot of take
away for that for other races as well
since you've got a lot of people sort of
clamoring down there you got cory booker
down there people who clearly want to
make this an issue going forward in 2018
and 2020 so it's gonna be our first test
so if he wins let's assume for sake of
argument more wins what will be the
message for other politicians that are
dealing with their own sexual misconduct
allegations is the message you know if i
deny deny deny and make it about a fake
news washington establishment conspiracy
against me I can hang on well or that
you're a Republican in Alabama and
that's a specific state
I mean bigger picture so Joan says if he
wins and you know our poll had him up
ten as of yesterday they said if he won
that it would be because a Democrat
could win in Alabama and that is in
doubt yeah many years because it's about
as deep red as any state can be a
president Trump Kimberly won by 28
points so more could lose by news
Republicans by 25 points and still eke
out a win yeah so it's gonna come down
to really just getting the the vote out
and who was more persuasive and doing
that in compelling voters to get out
there and make sure the Democrats have a
lot to gain by having an upset here so I
would expect that their ground game
would be good but the advantage you
would think would go to the Republican
candidate but president Trump really
waited a little bit to get in this and
doing kind of a last-minute robo call
yeah he stood down and didn't you know
condemn him like others in the
Republican Party did but is that gonna
be enough to give the push to kind of
have that popularity and groundswell of
support for president Trump transfer
over to Roy you know you know I have to
say I've been pretty hard on more and I
think I've changed my mind on him did
you know that his lawyer is a Jew worst
rumor is black and his best tailor is
gay I'm in you're in I'm in and I don't
even vote in Alabama but the problem
with this whole election is give us some
context lawyers a Jew that's important
yeah because you want to make sure that
no one thought they were anti-semitic so
just said hey you know yeah our legal
team the set I said this before I feel
bad for the Alabamans because they are
presented with an almost an artificially
polarizing polarizing choice if you vote
Democrat therefore you're voting for an
anti-gun you know anti-life approach
your pro portion and you're gonna burn
in hell but if you vote for more you're
voting for a pedophile and you're gonna
burn in hell
that's the two choices you have I love
America we only have two choices either
the pedophile or it's the Kombi traitor
yes right well that's what the hell he's
say in Alabama especially if you're
black and your civil rights activism but
let me just say in explaining what you
were talking
about that he has said things about
George Soros who's a Democrat big
fundraiser for the Democrats and Jewish
yeah I suggested oh well doesn't matter
Soros that doesn't believe in Christ
he's going to hell anyway mm-hmm and
that's what then started the whole
discussion about is the anti-semitic but
today I think you know by the way can
believe I think President Trump by going
on to Pensacola and getting involved in
the Alabama media market was making in a
pitch and it's been very clear that he
is endorsing Roy Moore it's still a
little late in the game he didn't
endorse him to begin with and there was
news today from Mitch McConnell who said
Luther strange is gonna stay in the
Senate through the end of this term no
matter what so he's gonna have that
Republican vote if that's the concern